the Los Angeles Clippers have won game
seven
and they advance to the second round
with tears of joy down the face of their
first year coach
[Applause]
I certainly remember Darren Davis
Curry splits the defense behind the back
fires a three
accidents that is spectacular move but
it's the largest lead of the game the
defense forced eight turnovers in that
third but this was certainly the
Highlight pluck of the day Stephen Curry
down the three the Warriors outscored
them 30 to eight teams Steve Kerr can't
believe it
[Applause]
[Music]
all right shakes all out of his boots
and hits a Fall Away jump shot you want
to see a dribble move watch this one
double behind your back knock it down
and the bench is loving it
coming at Chris Paul takes it out under
the basket and suddenly goes two times
behind his back to leave Paul on the
ground and then finishes it off 1-2 Paul
goes down Curry knocks down the jump
shot this guy is something special he's
just taking a look at James Harden all
the way down
Paul said Curry to the floor and Tucker
the pocket by Paul King goes on here
because of that leg injury well it's
only a sixth game back Curry just went
down on that move by Paul who's Carl
Tucker
in the shot clock
Paul
that's the first one
[Applause]
in the third quarter and 59 and Chris
Paul going into the Buddy of Steph Curry
and a little answer from Chris
so Chris Paul trying to stay with Steph
stepped out in the lane
[Applause]
what is some Wizardry look he's talking
crazy to him too saying they can't guard
him draymond's almost at the half court
line flexing for he was just not taking
No important answer Chris Paul tried to
keep him on that Baseline Steph is like
I'm gonna get to this Rim if it's the
last thing did I do
well wait look he's chirping look he's
talking to him he can't he can't guard
me I'm too strong we talk about that
Curry does not get the free throw love
of many other